Bình ngày hôm tư thông em một chính thức lệ thật cao theo đi lo sâu lệ sạch mạng lưỡi tội phạm
mà Washington cao buộc gió tổng thống Vinh Nhi Jela,
Nhi Colas, Mà Đồ Rô Câm Đau và Văn Sách tổ chức khủng bụn nguyện
Mình chậu đó cũng đã truy knảo Mà Đồ Rô với số tiền thường lên tự
Năm trậu đồ, ngoài trường miếm mắt có rub bí ô cho biệt
Đốc thay mời sẻ kéo theo lập chế tay trong khủng bộ vô sông lên Vinh Nhi Jela
Chính phủ Vinh Nhi Jela lập tức bắt bỏ
Cảo buộc Washington đã đi ở dạm một tổ chức măng tên cao theo đi lo sâu lệ sạch
Nằm tim cờ cắt thì quân sức từ đó lất đổ chứng quên
và tìm sát mòn tảng bên dấu kỹ, vang, và kìv lạc kỹ của nước này
Đốc thay mời sẻ ra khi Mỹ đang chình khai lực lượng kuy mộ lỡ
nó khai bê, gồm nhóm tạc chến tổ sân vài trẻ áo phô, tông nân tân công
nhiều tầu cuu chục, tìm cức et mạm lắm, mạc bái đổ bộ
mạc bái không ở lại mở cuy chiến cùng mời nghĩ bình sĩ
ngoài ra Mỹ cũng tiến hành hàng loạt cuộc không kích tưu diện tổ thuyên
bị nghĩ trở mắt tìm ngoài khơi bên dưới la và thái bình dương
Rồi tờ trước đó, đưa tin, Washington cũng đang chuyển bị đước sáng dài đoạn hàng động mới
tại bên dưới la, kích bản lực đổ, tổn thống niệng của lác mặt đủ đồ cũng có thể đã đuất nhà trắng thảo loạt
tổn chứ ông Trump bố mắt đủ đều đẹp ngọt khả năng đối thoại thử định
tuy nhiên vẫn chưa có đoạn thái xuống thang căng thẳng nào từ cao 2 phía